I think that the importance of a culture
is is to create Unity amongst the
company how do you create Unity I think
that it's Clarity in the company's
vision
and getting buy-in on that vision and
having everybody understand the why
my name is John Walsh I'm the founder
and CEO of Endura and we manufacture
electric school buses and electric
shuttle buses in Ottawa Ohio I founded
era five years ago I was in private
equity and I got assigned an electric
bus company
I got to learn the ins and outs of Evie
through that experience after a year I
left and I started in Dara the next day
this is the third clean tech company I
founded so I've always been into the
environment and I saw it as a tremendous
opportunity
I met John early on and it caught me off
guard how young he was
it was interesting to see
how many young people are involved in
this I'm the old guy around here right
and these guys are half my age it's
pretty cool
I think that Indira they've chosen a
very good place because
Ottawa Putnam County
the potential employees all have a very
good work ethic
and our infrastructure is is very good
we're spending like nine million dollars
on our water plant to upgrade it in our
Industrial Park we've got many acres out
there that also has you know water sewer
it's ready to go for you know any new
startups
Indira is in the old campus that used to
be Phillips display components Phillips
at one point was employing over 2500
people they shut down and move so we
went from 1940s technology and now we
have new technology and part of the
facility that they had it's really
awesome to see what we got going and how
industry and businesses are responding
to that
[Music]
we acquired Phillips's old manufacturing
plant they used to manufacture tube TVs
here in the 70s all the way up to early
2000s the benefit of the factory to
Indira is is that it's perfectly
situated for automotive and so
it gave us the infrastructure that we
needed to come in Acquire The Factory
and then adopt our EV technology as a
vertically integrated manufacturing
process
[Music]
so this is the first station on the EV
Line This is the mechanical section this
is where holes get drilled brackets get
mounted and it gets prepped for the
second station where you have the
plumbing of the EB so this is where all
the high voltage the low voltage
harnesses the thermal architecture gets
laid in
in prep for the next station which is
where you get all the batteries and the
sub-assemblies that get put into place
and the last station is really focused
on high intensity electronics and
testing
[Music]
how's it going guys
doing good you might show me what you
guys are doing here
Yeah man so we're uh basically finishing
knob or thermal system
in addition to that we're stunning high
voltage cables after the step will be
getting ready to put battery packs yeah
drivetrain and all of that so this is
where all the magic happens
this station here is where you see a
fully assembled Powertrain this is 150
kilowatt hours right now we're doing
about one a day but our goal is to scale
up by the end of the year to do six a
day
and that's just with one line and so we
can do up to six lines in this Factory
there's no robots involved in our
process it's it's a very labor intensive
process it's special to Evie so there's
a bunch of different ways you can
configure it and that means that we get
employed people
[Music]
we have employees that have worked at
the Phillips manufacturing plant for
generation and then now we have those
same people working at Indira not only
are those people working in Dara but
their children are working here
their husbands wives are working here
we have multiple sets of families that
are working at in Dara
[Music]
my sister works here my brother is soon
to start my cousin my nephew and a
couple of friends
it was tough the one of the Phillips
plant closed I had to look for another
job right away
now that I've been here for a year
they've made it possible for us to buy
our own home
it's an honest working place they listen
to you they care about you they take
care of us
getting there in Ohio we have 410 work
schedules so everybody has a three-day
weekend
also we make sure that everybody is paid
well and that we have a bonus program
everybody at their also has stock
that's really important to me to get
everybody to think like owners
I came from the finance community
so I've always tried to take my Approach
in building this company as if I was an
investor because I have invested a great
deal into the company
getting on a State Contractor getting
awarded a state contract is cumbersome
up front and then you have a multi-year
component to the contract so it takes
anywhere from six months to upwards of a
year
to get that contract and then once
you're on that contract you're on that
contract for multiple years
there's a lot of recurring Revenue that
we get when we sell the vehicle as well
we're talking about the software as a
service solutions charging as a service
and so treating myself as an investor
and putting myself in their shoes as the
guardian of their capital is very
important to me and
I would think that they respect that
[Music]
what makes endera Stand Out is the
quality by far it's the best van and bus
on the market
I'm Joe Pritchard the CEO of Pritchard
companies the builder of the bodies
the pandemic with Supply chains have
really stressed the production line
you read some things in the paper like
EVS here tomorrow but the infrastructure
and the different elements that go into
a quality powertrain will take longer
and We're a nation that really likes
things right away and that would be one
of the biggest threats that I see that
people get impatient because they want
the product now and we're not going to
deliver a product until it's ready
this is not a Sprint it's a marathon
that's where I think some of the
guidance of myself and the other board
members have been helpful for for John
to say you know as much change is going
on we're still in the first inning
for my previous experiences in starting
clean tech companies I learned that you
have to have an economic value
proposition
in addition to an environmental
proposition to have true impact I also
learn the importance of company culture
and having a group of people that are
really aligned in their interests and
motivated towards a common goal and I
also learned how to raise Capital as a
significant lesson learned
when I first started the company it was
it was just me and a couple of interns
and we had a subcontract manufacturer
business model
that unfortunately was not scalable we
raised 21 million dollars in 2021 as a
first seed round and that was to bring
our powertrain technology in-house to
acquire the factory that we're in today
and to to get to production and then we
just closed a larger round in December
of last year that really has allowed us
to scale our production in a significant
way
[Music]
Ottawa is a great place to manufacture
Ohio is a great place to manufacture
it's the commercial automotive capital
of the country and it's quickly becoming
known as the Silicon Valley for electric
vehicles
building in Ohio has its advantages
because it is definitely economical to
have a business here there's very
business friendly laws and logistically
for andera it's a good centerpiece for
access to all the different states so
shipping and Logistics are very easy
here
when we moved to Ottawa we found it to
be a great place for us to park our flag
because we saw it had a lot of the
properties that we needed to have a
manufacturing facility and the facility
itself is situated to do over 3 000 EV
buses a year out of that factory alone
and so it gave us the ability to scale
and that was really a significant factor
in our decision to come to Ottawa
what surprised me in coming to Ohio from
California is
you have a really strong family culture
here especially like the local watering
holes is where everybody really goes and
congregates families people young and
old all go to these local bar
restaurants and
that was actually part of what we did to
start getting recognition was we would
go there just to start meeting people
and let people know that that we're here
and that we're here to stay
it's also a very affordable place
I mean affordable place to manufacture
but affordable place to live
what we've seen is we've seen property
values go up and we've seen that there's
been a huge influx of job applications
at endara when we first came people
didn't know who we were and in this town
trust is a big factor in wanting to work
at any place and and so we've had to
build trust by getting in with the
community we've we've done sponsorships
to Special Olympics bowling tournaments
we've worked with little league teams
and race car events to to let people
know that we're here
Ottawa Ohio was perfect fit for endear
you've got a great talent pool of
commercial automotive workers that know
how to work on
vehicles
[Music]
there's a valley of death over the last
decade in Evie in cleantech in general
and and now we're at an inflection point
where you do have that economic value
proposition in addition to an
environmentally beneficial solution
I think to get more Americans to switch
to EVS there has to be somewhat of an
education that
driving EV is better than driving a gas
vehicle
it is
it just hits I mean you don't have to go
to a gas station ever it's more fun to
drive oftentimes most CVS are more
integrated with your phone like I don't
even have a key I just walk up my car
opens and
it's better for the environment so I
think education is is what's needed
a second thing I would say is
infrastructure I think that the big fear
is range anxiety
and I think that we can solve that
through high power DC fast charging in
more remote areas that people want to go
to once in a blue moon the reality is
those is 95 percent of the time that EV
is going to be able to do what you need
in your normal daily commute so
Education Plus infrastructure I think
are the two main things
[Music]
school buses and shuttle buses are
unique in the EV landscape because they
have a lot of government backing on one
side where it's serving a public good a
public need and that is historically
Recession Proof it's very price
inelastic which is good in inflationary
environment and you don't want your
children breathing diesel smoke
I think that you know that on top of the
environmentally beneficial elements of
EV is of value and and I think that
people are seeing that
[Music]
we were awarded in February the Cal act
contract as the low bid vendor it's an
estimated thousand EV buses are being
procured off of this contract over the
next five years
and so we're really excited we're
ramping up production to to serve that
contract as well as others across the
country
the demand in the school bus and the
shuttle bus Market are tremendous
and Derek can't build them fast enough
[Music]
I met John through my son the Next
Generation he was doing some work on
alternative fuels and he met John at a
conference
the partnership started when we were
supplying the chassis of course we were
building the buses as well and you know
John's Vision was you know way out there
and this kind of pulled forward his
vision
what was interesting for me to say okay
you know you uh you can forge your own
way and you guys got great plans and
ideas and we have a shell of a company
that you can take and move into the
future
my great-grandfather started the company
in 1913 and was instrumental in Paving
the roads in fact where our home store
is in Iowa that was the first connection
of Two Cities with paved roads and to be
able to sit and look back and say you
know my great-grandfather was involved
in this and now we have the talent of
John and the Next Generation involved in
The Cutting Edge
spot of the change that people will look
back on a calendar and say you know 2023
2024 that's when the Pioneers in EV
started it's very rewarding I'd take a
lot of pride in that similarity
[Music]
we've got contracts in Florida we've got
contracts in New Jersey New York Oregon
Washington Colorado so you're starting
to see the momentum in state by state
new contracts come out that are EV
[Music]
I see Ottawa pretty much on The Cutting
Edge of this is where you want to go for
new technology this is what Ottawa has
to offer
I just think we've got a great thing
going here and I I can't wait to see
what's what's what in five to ten years
[Music]
I'm very grateful for the opportunity
for for having hit the right timing and
I guess luck is when preparation meets
opportunity maybe but I think it's been
rewarding it's been hard excruciating
sleepless nights sometimes I mean I'm
pulling
13 14 hour days in this Factory to to
get it up and running and especially
when we first acquired the company and
how to get everybody integrated you know
when you when you buy a company
there's a lot of fear in the employees
and and so you know we had to have a
huge emphasis on ensuring that look
we're here to
to grow you guys into you know having a
career-long opportunity
I hope we're here for a long long time
and we grow like Phillips did and you
know we just keep prospering
I would see in Dara as being the leading
bus producer and manufacturer in their
space and that is school bus and shuttle
bus they will build the best product
with Cutting Edge technology and will be
the go-to for all the transportation
needs for a cleaner environment
we want to be a disrupter we want to get
more people in electric buses so next
year we intend to deliver just under a
thousand vehicles and we plan to ramp up
to 3 000 Vehicles by 2027.
I asked myself this question a lot of
like why are we here what are we doing
what does this all mean what is it for
and
you know what do I want to look at
myself
as an elderly man on my deathbed and I
think that it would be that I would want
to have been known as someone that leads
the world and
made a positive impact on humanity and
was love for it
that gives me peace
[Music]